si vous partez pour le raid saint martin
il faut penser à certaines choses avant
d'embarquer en canoë d'abord il faut une
bonne tenue avec des baskets vous pouvez
garder votre tenue de course à pied ou
le vélo
ensuite il faut mettre le gilet
attention si vous avez des lunettes et
bien avoir un cordon ou alors de les
enlever
donc on a enfilé le gilet soit par le
haut soit comme une chemise selon gilles
et que vous avez et ensuite il faut
penser à bien le serré pour éviter que
ça remonte sous le menton vous pouvez
prendre votre paquet en faisant
attention à bien placer vos mains sur
les scotchs et après si vous avez les
mains fragiles vous pouvez utiliser des
gants qui peut qu'en de vélo pour pas
gagné avant de vous élancer sur le raid
saint martin c'est bien de s'entraîner
un petit peu avant en canoë et surtout
de vous entraîner être synchronisé c'est
à dire que quand le premier suit qui a
l'avantagé à gauche le second quai à
l'arrière le suit et pagaie aussi à
gauche et en même temps c'est bien si
vous pouvez définir les places avant
souvent mais plutôt le plus fort à
l'avant parce que c'est le moteur est
celui qui dirige est plutôt mis à
l'arrière du canoë s'il ya une grosse
différence de poids entre les deux
participants c'est mieux quand même de
mettre personne la plus lourde à
l'arrière du canoë et puis après c'est
parti pour embarquer fabienne mentale
arrière elle va diriger le canoë et moi
je veux la rejoindre à l'avant pour
faire le moteur entre saint-benoît et
déguisés oui c'est faisable moi je fais
souvent mes entraînements là-bas et
l'eau est calme il n'y a pas de problème
allez bonne course
[Musique]